okay people join in the livestream this
is talking about incremental
improvements to often language for
future versions
okay so first up we have a new potential
function called thread inside do we have
alternate names for that yet I'm not
really this is more like experimenting
with a function so that's a prototype
what do you just evaluate it and yeah
the first thing I wanted to listen why
am I getting that message could not
process unknown packet or failed
um okay go ahead yes so so this is a
small issue that is important for when
we use threading with negative number of
levels the fact that these two first
inputs give the same output so in a
sense this is not truly invertible know
what so we need to decide when we thread
back F one level which of these two do
we return which I think should is the
second one because it's the general case
as demonstrated by the third input yes
I'm not sure I understand okay look I
need to remind myself what's gonna
happen here
so sorry this is too weird this not
could not process packet fail let me
just try something here
that's really weird I'm trying to delete
that and isn't working I'm gonna quit
this whole session and restart
who knows what I've been doing here it's
probably got some oh oh oh that was what
that was that was version 12.1 who knows
what that was doing okay it was software
from the future um software from the
very I mean yeah very early in the
release cycle somebody might want to
report that or it might not be worth the
trouble
yo just reported that it wasn't opening
sessions correctly okay good section
okay so do we have a description again
of what this is doing inside what would
be the one-line description of what this
does it's moving heads up and down and
yes
well inside is not the worst name for
that um okay so quilling to the explicit
thread inside with one level okay thread
inside one level F that's the head we
push inside okay that's the head pushed
inside that's the head left outside so
if I said G here it would do nothing
exactly okay
and that says but now if I said
something other than a list so there's
only one correct answer right so here we
are threading through levels of of a
race and so least is what we are
specifying what is in ring everything
else is considered a scaler like this X
yes I understand so so for example if we
were to say thread inside list vertical
bar G or something let's try for example
something like this if we said this and
then that's X Y no G of X Y I mean in
theory would it work so what that's
doing is it's using its pushing the head
app no but because those heads are going
to be collected and put at the upper
level they have to be the same so we
cannot thread through several heads at
the same time so what does this what
point was the point of saying this it's
just it's just don't do it consider the
thing to be a scalar and just don't
thread it all well you would have to say
threads list or threads through G
I change that to Gina and now the list
is considered scalar yeah that's
interesting
there's an interesting operation
okay so fred has by the way these same
arguments so the fourth argument of
thread insight is the second document of
threat but thread doesn't have the other
two we're at the fourth argument or the
oh yeah because that's what to thread
over so if I say thread F of G of X Y G
of Z W whatever comma G right doesn't it
have a level spec as well no it doesn't
and that's a problem with threat
it's only threats once okay okay by once
we mean it doesn't rodenticide a head in
I think we used to have a notion back in
version 0.9 we had the notion of rodent
efficacious that is burrowing like a
rodent unfortunately that was removed
it's just as well um okay so in to here
yeah it goes all the way down exactly
okay there's no notion of it going to
more than one level it's just go it just
goes down and then deploys itself okay
and it will do the same thing that's
right so if it doesn't find enough
levels of one it will just replicate so
if yeah that's right okay you can do -
two of that output now because you have
to specify the head you have to really
say no you have to really say F because
otherwise is going to try the outermost
which is list I three and you see how
the X was replicated that was that was
the issue I was mentioning before yeah I
understand I think that's okay but let's
look at what the operation is in the
case of list okay so if I say thread
inside and then list a b c d this is
gonna do a transpose operation isn't it
okay so now if I do thread inside that
-1 oops that's not what I meant
okay that's also transpose in this case
but if I have a deeper tensor so if I
say thread inside of array a 3 3 3 comma
minus 2 what does that do I think it's a
transpose of some kind it is but it's
not trivial because here it's realizing
that there are two levels now only the
deepest one can be moved
so this I know here it's realizing that
it can move two there are three levels
and there are two that can be moved
upwards one so this gets I'm okay okay
so wait so if I said here if I say pull
it from the deepest ocean so to speak
even I say this thing with minus three
when you specify to many it's going to
do as much as it can you cannot just say
minus infinity and it will try to go as
deep as it can and move it as upwards as
much as it can okay this case is
particularly tricky because by default
is always trying to move the outermost
head which is list and because in this
case there are several levels of Lists
it's going to try to move them all so
this is simpler to understand in those
cases in which there is a single had to
move to be moved yeah okay all right
okay but this this looks reasonable okay
so then
yeah okay well this function is fine I
think they're their only thing to to
decide it was this issue of of whether
to replicate common element so much and
something yes I think yes I don't have a
problem with that these are more less
common examples and then at the end
there is an application to your position
which is what where we started the
kitchen can't take that case which is
lists of lists of points and sometimes
we need to push that your position head
one or twice yes and that will that will
exhume your positions from the deepest
depths threads twice ok what do we think
the description of thread inside would
be so wait a minute the one argument
thread inside is equivalent to thread is
that correct completely ok so so just so
we understand what we might be saying
here why isn't that why is that saying
version 12 why isn't that defaulting to
12 one
okay so here what we would say is thread
inside and see what the thread
documentation looks like that's
interesting what it does there F of args
so in the case of thread inside it's
again an F of listed augs right now I
understand but even with two arguments
if n is positive um
threads have over lists that appear at
level n in hogs is that correct I would
say all the N levels of Lists okay okay
now the next case is the negative level
case um which doesn't look like this
does it well this is useful only if
there are deeper levels of F as well is
the negative is more useful when you
specify the third argument is the level
you want to move upward right so maybe
we have to do here is to say is to give
the three argument I mean we should we
can make the one argument case work
actually I think there's an argument
that we should not make it one argument
case work it's kind of stupid and it's
just formula for people doing the wrong
thing well that's also true yes let's
not have the one argument for work um
okay so here we would say the threads
over what is it threads how do we want
to say this this is are we going to with
positive n okay explain this to me what
this is yeah I would say threats F in X
in the given expression and levels of
list yes through n levels of Lists and
exper when it does
f occurs the outer it has to occur at
some level inside extra threads any
instances of f that occur in expo but
now we're gonna is it is it down to end
levels or a ten levels what was it what
is it it's if any specifics then it's in
levels down in explore that occur at
most and levels down in expose that
right well it sounds us the at most is
referring to the curve and levels down
and in expert side expert absolutely
should say threats and levels down in
expert any instances of f that occur
index pressure I don't understand okay
so you're saying threads and levels Tom
what does it mean it threads a nose down
I thought it was picking up only those
apps that are on level n yes I just
wanted to avoid we should say threads
instances of F that occur at level n in
Expo but that's not what it is it it
doesn't matter where F appears it will
just be pushed down angles I say what I
wanted to avoid is occur n times n yeah
I understand
threads any instances of F that occur
inside expert
correspond to this one threads well it's
threads over end locals of list any
instances of F that occur in an express
eyed expression okay now what about the
negative Louisville case if we document
this case yes so now we have to make the
distinction of threading down or
threading up I guess we have to invent
the names here because alone so we've
also got the case and that's exper again
right
without right yes okay so then we've got
thread inside exper and half key threads
over levels of G okay well let's cut the
simulator I mean I think I think a
[ __ ] good and so this last one will
say pulls it
it's was considering positive or
negative and so in that develop is
correct for both cases I think so Sandra
a live stream is saying that's gonna be
a hard function yeah it's gonna be a
function that one learns to use in
particular cases and one will slowly
slowly slowly get used to it
I give this for a few years for people
to get used to this one
I think that first
be fairly commonly understood yeah I
think some of these other cases are
really interesting and will turn out to
be really useful so I'm wondering
whether for example with lists and
associations we can pool we can do
things fast like moving Association say
that I don't know I don't know how this
is gonna work on associations I see
you're saying that this might be able to
take a list of associations I don't even
know how that would work does that work
list of associations to an association
of lists and things that worked
so imagine associations with values
being erase matrices to push the keys
yes okay so that this thing needs to
interoperate with associations it's not
obvious how that would work to me it's
it's got to be generalized a bit to work
with associations okay all right move on
so the ideas that we have tickets for
these functions but they are simple to
implement so it may go to the power from
repository and I think the main point is
I'm trying to understand the border
between the two projects yeah domicile
head map why is it that way round this
is what we discussed the previous time
some sort of dual of math in which we
could reverse the order
was the other makes sense I think head
map the other way around is it much more
sensible let's take a look here I don't
know whether that one mean maybe that
one could be a system function it's
pretty obvious and what it does and it's
it's just particularly you know if it
curries well I'm thinking you know okay
so this case here that's pretty useful
but now the curry of that other one
would be head map of F G H of X there's
no other way to do that is there well
beautiful also to have a list of data
set whose elements are functions and we
just want to this is one of those cases
in which could be useful to carry either
argument I think it's more natural if we
are going to put the functions first to
curry it this way around yes okay I
don't know why I say it but my tendency
is to think this should be a system
function but let's
look at some of us okay um okay I'm
saving this back somewhere oh my god I'm
saving it to some garbage place
Ethan our livestream is asking about
thread inside and wouldn't want to
control the levels heads and span
simultaneously I don't know the the
usable span the question of the span and
thread it's basically a selector for
when when this app you know we're in the
know sorry we're in the geez so right
away we're in the FS which arguments of
the apps to look at with respect to
threading so if this will become a
generalization of right yeah I
understand
and then the only reason this isn't
thread itself is because of the argument
order we should check that it will be
possible to add a am a span somehow but
would we put this pan is there is a span
of F sort of span of cheese it's right
it's span of although one could imagine
spans for both F and G yeah I mean we
could imagine decorating with a span
somehow with a rule or something like
this a little bit like how groupings
well this is how groupings does it
groupings works differently groupings is
is doing it with an ax
you know our tea
all right that's that's a question for
the read inside ok comment on our
livestream head map is just through with
the same argument structure I mean
through is not a successful function I
can never remember how through works oh
god yes yes this thing is crazy
through is two heads as thread is two
analysts somehow yes so threading and
map threat have similar relation the
fact that thread takes the expression
already constructed a mod thread has the
function outside livestreams writing a a
almost zero line huh forehead map that's
just this yeah well through with mistake
I think it's rare that we find lists us
heads that's why it's not so much used
right I mean the thought of through was
that it will be used for operators right
I mean the idea was but you know this
was a version one function right the
idea was that operate
Yeah right right this is like an
operator flying itself to the head so
for example derivative could be an
operate um you know derivative that like
just as derivative is you get what I'm
saying yes operator could have been it's
nothing that positions here right right
I mean look the basic point was the bet
made 30 years ago 31 years ago by the
way we have a bunch of somebody needs to
meet themselves in it um the the bet
made Thank You Danny
um the bat made was that one would use
composite heads as operators operators
in some mathematical type sense okay
that didn't happen people have not found
that convenient I believe um all right
our our live stream folk are encouraging
head map what one reason is that it
could perhaps be the function that
through and and operate never quite
became it might just it's a one-liner
but it might hit the right need yeah I
think that's correct I think it's
correct and I think particularly in the
curried form it's pretty nice and I
think it's name is understandable that's
a big distinction between that and
through yeah well the point is look
through was a bet I mean it's
interesting it's an interesting case
because it's a design idea that for as
of still thirty years later it hasn't
worked out I'm not convinced that it's
never going to work out um you know if
head
became more popular it might actually
work out headdresses being things like
essentially adverbs controlling
functions that wrap the head in some way
like inactive wraps the head I bet that
inactive and through could play very
nicely together but I just don't think
people think you know it's hard enough
for people to think in terms of function
functions let alone these kinds of head
decorators should be an example it
should be an example yes it should be an
example as should operate with
derivative right I mean operator of
derivatives should just work say two or
something comma f of X does that see
isn't that magnificent
I mean that was the original idea of
operate was to do things like that and
by the way that example really really
really should be them yes I mean
yeah I mean these honestly these are not
totally stupid by any means I mean
otherwise there's no easy way to do this
I mean it's not even a bad name operate
well it's difficult it's going to do
that's why my Butthead I think good to
have been clearer but Langer um okay two
questions here so comment from sander
that head map does sound a bit like it
maps onto the head as opposed to map
head
no because map head is more like map at
head as in map I mean that's operates
precisely you can do map at position
zero right so there's a thing from Stock
Exchange here
okay list of triples best way to fight
after the first honours of each triple
oh I see so it's a deeper level version
of head map well I mean it could take an
argument with this argument ordering it
would happily take a third argument that
is a level spec but actually that's not
clear how it composes because it's more
like an inner to go across and get what
I'm saying I mean in other words all
right that requires a bit more thought
okay let us ponder that question and
maybe we can get back to that another
time but I think I think we're good for
I think the two argument form is looking
promising and the one and two argument
forms are looking promising okay let's
look at all cases so this was a
diversion
okay um yeah actually several comments
on our live stream I'm not convinced
about that one looks like head apply so
somebody else says and Genesis why is it
why is it head why such a saying no yes
no it isn't
not slicing off a layer it's not it is a
map doesn't apply right yes um lists
through no I guarantee no one will ever
understand that list map to generic
sounding yeah I know that the senator is
commenting in there and the hum in the
post in that post it's asking for the
different functions to be applied in a
threaded way to the successive levels
requires the use of maps right combined
possibly with this that's possible
I see so a curried form of head map
together with map thread somehow boy one
day we're actually gonna give people
some real things to teach and functional
programming classes by the time people
have learned you know their way around
all of these different head gymnastics
and so on it's quite interesting really
um okay
all cases yes so disappeared because we
have first case this particular case of
cases we discuss the possibility of
having four cases well first case is a
single-level the first case that occurs
in that yeah
first case that occurs in that list
right yeah I mean this one looks like a
fine function repository function for
the time being it's utility but I don't
really see it as being core that seems
like a fine function repository function
what why is it not the same as oh I see
any true and all true are different
thing here yes because yeah so this is
this is the same test
not even a same test it's at it's a yeah
I understand what this is find function
repository function right so or I mean
you know it's an equivalence it's it's
are they all a member of the same
equivalence class under sound
transformation okay
trim yes so the idea here is that we
have several extreme functions but we
don't have a general dream for arrays
that this can be done with padding
because padding takes negative specs so
there is trim right and trim left in
function repository oh really yes I
suppose it's this coming from that's
right okay let me look at those
um you know we are going to have to
invent a guide page mechanism for this
functions yeah
okay is that what you had in mind for
trim mmm yes very close to it so yeah it
makes sense to us to surprise functions
except if it's two-dimensional what does
this do if it is trimming
I mean image trim trims on all sides
right yes and also image trim is a
content-related trim isn't it doesn't
image trim um depend on I had one oh
gosh that's image crop I see so much
trim this doesn't tell you so this
should have another form which is a two
argument form that says how much to trim
trim left should be able to give you a
specific look at the part left I was
assuming this would be very similar to
their patent functions
yeah yeah I think so
makes the list of life then so trim left
would make a list of length n I mean am
pad left of one argument pads the ragged
array yeah I I think this is a look I
think this is probably going to make it
as a system function but we might as
well implement it in the function
repository for the time being if it
follows spot left it's going to be
nearly identical to but left
perhaps just changing the signs of any
yes sorry I don't think yeah I agree
it's gonna be very similar yeah not the
sign but the fact that n can be shorter
than the length and any dreams yeah but
also it doesn't have a padding argument
and all kinds of other stuff
I mean well if n is longer than the
length it might need a padding argument
but I prefer for it to just error out I
think in that case okay so I think for
the time being trim left trim right
should go in the front repository
Association flat yeah it's better to
look at the examples so the idea is that
for nested associations the idea was to
flatten them to a single Association
with lists of keys that should be in the
function of poetry I have no idea if
that operation is gonna be useful nested
lock up so this is a version of look at
which is also able to look inside
ministers associations I think it should
be in the function of buzzer tried on
how useful it's gonna be histogram
Association
oh yeah really that's a thing where the
big idea here is intervals yes to me
this is an alternative notation for
histogram lists yes I agree but
histogram lists doesn't have the left
hand side right histogram lists it's
just the purely the the values of the
bin values isn't it no the first list is
the Border's oh there we go okay oh
that's weird
well it's a
to repository function because again I
don't know if it's exactly right
Egyptian fraction compatibility with the
past says I took the code from a semi
school project okay looks quite
elaborate actually and perhaps of even
efficient okay what does this do so so I
think it's it's taking numerator
denominator and then two numerators so
the one one are the first numerators of
the first two fractions so you have to
find the denominators and a remainder
people pointing out the nested look up
already exists in the function
repository so that's a null operation
and Ethan is pointing out that we need
to not add too many typed weird corner
cases and I agree with that which is why
his things are getting put in the
function repository um because I think
ultimately we may understand how to do
these things in a more general way
alright I thought Egyptian fractions
were by default one numerator things am
I wrong about that I think I was talking
to Todd Rowland long time ago and he
mentioned that this is not exactly
Egyptian fraction but like a case of it
well that's not good enough I mean and
you know the Egyptians were around for a
long time okay so what does wolf Malfoy
use do we know
I was saying Egyptian fraction also
exists even went to the wrong repository
that's amusing um when is this one gonna
be done by the way um ha oh my gosh
where does the method get given you mean
definition no I mean it should just say
has the option method because there is
it's not clear what this is yeah I would
I would strongly recommend that that's a
table okay well this is magnificent
right so much for that okay that was
easy okay is just you should restart a
discussion of relations so do I um let
me just ask a question about me just
look at the aisle these summary pages um
again because I wanted to know
Sushma how much of this have we now gone
through the the so-called low-hanging
stuff we have gone through I mean III
need to check my notes but we did go
through a lot of them and you know
as a potential function repository the
ones I think the ones which you put like
stars potential function repository but
I think I think D trend should be
considered as a system function okay
it's very useful and I think that would
be a question for Roger and the
statistics team okay notebook history
functions did those get added to the
repository no I've not seen them yet so
I don't think because that should be
very easy but it's kind of useful that's
basically getting a computable form of
this incredibly old-fashioned I mean
this is cool because you know it's
showing we just need to get I mean by
the way somebody should do this is a
good like ui/ux
intern project to just clean up that the
appearance of this thing I mean it's
really
being very good but I could give you
much more useful to have a programmatic
way to get the stuff out and it requires
it thinking why did that pink okay
another question is this view here is
not a completely uninteresting view for
timeline plots and we should investigate
some kind of dynamic timeline plot
having that kind of why is it pinking
why is that clicking I'm not clicking
I'm simply hovering yeah you know what
what's that oh yes it's it's on some
kind of transition over that bottom line
causes it to pink okay so look the trend
I think should be something considered
for system stuff I'll be okay although I
think it should actually be limited by
the statistics team um no quick history
can be in the function repository what
happened to next moon I think I have it
to get the bad in function repository
function depository I'll show you
built-in it's pretty it's pretty you
know by the time we have moon phase it
seems to me that next moon is a relevant
thing okay I mean just like we have you
know the next day type stuff what what
is it called anyway day X date so if I
say next date why isn't that also
completing can we note that down Auto
completion but anyway next date
we should have next moon I mean you know
we're stuck on this planet we got one
moon there's really not you know it's a
thing that's that's I don't think we
need to worry about you know we'll worry
about the Martian case later do we want
it looks like in that one we have a
optional third argument that's direction
do we want that or I'm assuming previous
moon and current moon are probably less
for a moon look yeah I know moon phase
would give us moon phase will give us
the current stays yes um oh yeah sander
is pointing out that it's similar to
sunrise but I think it has to be next
moon because even next moon with zero
arguments it's not obvious what that
means because you might want full or new
or whatever and in my basic astronomer
right that the the unlike sunrise which
has a location dependence we also have
solar eclipse which is also our next
something function yeah well
unfortunately dynamics of yes the solar
eclipse of sunrise obviously takes a
location spec but the moon phase does
not require a location spec notice next
moon require a location spec right am i
being confused in any way I mean the
only way it could require it is by is
the timezone that's the only reason and
the moon may not be visible but the moon
will still be whatever the moon is in
terms of I guess it depends how precise
we want to be the fact that you are in a
different position of the moon we
introduce a little bit of difference in
angles from what a good analysis and
it's not a the numeron is the first
lunar phase when the moon and sun have
the same ecliptic longitude that's fine
but that that's the ecliptic longitude
does not depend on where you are on the
earth right how do we request the next I
see next total so if I say solar eclipse
total here that's really weird
I don't understand this I don't
understand this now option Eclipse type
try Eclipse theis eclipse type goes to
tapa
okay so now I see okay so if I say total
phase polygon yeah I mean the problem is
that these things require slightly
different and I now say gee oh well like
a cheerless thought or Geographics of
that magnificent okay that's magnificent
um okay look I I think that next moon is
simply a missing function given that we
have things like sunrise and and solar
eclipse you know next moon is a lot less
obscure than solar eclipse would it make
sense to make next date to take things I
was thinking about that I was wondering
about that I think it's a little bit
weird yeah right now next previous and
current either take a granularity or a
day type specification I think thinking
about phases of a lunar cycle is a
little bit of a stretch I agree
I don't think another think of it so
next date it doesn't have an N in it
where you can have three from now that's
day plus
I see I suppose we could have it but
then it really is just a different
version of date plus and we already had
my a plus which is already kind of a
confusing difference right but so the I
as sander points out next moon should
certainly be able to take a phase
argument so next moon should be able to
take like I have here 0.7 oh that's
interesting so in the two argument form
of next date it starts with the date and
then and then has the granularity but I
don't think we have to do so for next
moon do we really need a previous moon I
mean we don't have for solar eclipse see
what is the generic solar eclipse is
asking about properties for solar
eclipse
moon phase I don't think we can shoe on
the center moon phase that's the wrong
thing to do because what we want is
solar eclipse takes a time direction so
it can be -1 and did you count so it
gives you the last fine I think next
moon should just be we should just have
next moon and we should not have
previous moon big previous moon is
unnecessary and pedantic unless there's
a more generic way to say next which I
don't see something about solar eclipse
that was always a bit unfortunate is
that do you ask for a solar eclipse to
get one and then you ask for solar
eclipses of that date and you get the
next one not that one but thanks
stupid why did we do that I mean cuz it
says next so this if next has this this
is a temporal logic issue again and and
I mean I think that we should take the
point of view that next okay the problem
is with a granularity okay with an
instantaneous granularity in the
continuum I could argue that next is
that instant with a granularity of a day
next day is clearly the next day that I
could argue that the degenerate form of
next is epsilon in the future with
epsilon goes to 0 and if it's an instant
then it's the same instant right so the
width of an instant next enos is by
virtue of the width of the thing that
you are you know next Inge so to speak
if for the granularity is a day then
it's the next day if it's the next
instant it's actually the same instant
there's an instant has zero width I
think it's not how this assumption works
well but it probably should be how it
works and I just don't think I think
that's a silly definition I don't think
I think it's wrong and I don't think is
there not a way to get I mean we should
have a way to get multiple solar
eclipses a list of solar eclipses and if
there isn't a way we should make that
work yeah but it's the ability I think
it's important we should have some sort
of minimum I mean they are not going to
be sore eclipses very close to each
other so so we can resolve them no no I
agree I agree this it seems like Jeff
should take a look at this and also take
a time direction seems kind of random
this looks like a color of cruddy
function if I might say so I think this
was imitating what limit does takes this
sort of direction oh wow well if we're
going to do that you know arguably
what's another thing like next moon I
mean it will be the the you know if if
astrology was still a booming business
we would need all kinds of functions
before you know next conjunction of
mercury and this and so on
right I mean really what this is is next
syzygy or something is that right yes
mr. amis there will be lots of
particular moments to compute and
hopefully in the future we will have a
function which is general in that sense
you know I guess the other analogy I
think of is you know in terms of
temperature there's max temperature
where you want to know what the maximum
temperature on a given day is but a
property of that would be the time at
which that happens which we don't really
have a function that is well we have
working the function repository because
I put one that yeah called Max position
mmm which arguably we should have as a
system function look I think you know
what we'll need in astronomy is
basically given a condition actually
kind of an interesting case because
astronomy is predictable given a
condition when will that next be
achieved
right so for example we might have a
condition that says you know these two
planets are lined up I don't know how
we're gonna represent that well I guess
we're gonna say some property of mercury
equals equals some property of Venus and
we're going to say basically it's the
analog of you know find root or
something yeah so I mean this is
basically not wishing to sound too you
know this is basically find this is
Susy geez as their right fine scissor
juice Sandra livestream is pointing out
that by this we should also have next
birthday of entity or person how would
we do that well what we would do there
is we would say next date you know it's
sort of our recurring date notion of
setting up some criteria so let's say
that we say next date of year and the
base and I we start from the base um
so that's not useful
yeah it's giving you the granularity so
why I guess I think what you want there
is date plus you want well I want the
what I want take plus is the next mmm
that's not gonna work
that's very unusable so what is next
birthday in terms of dates it's the next
time it has to granularities involved in
it right mm-hmm
it's something similar to it isn't the
same thing but we have a we have future
eyes docks for a function called dates
select where you give a criteria so it's
not in the proper system yeah but it's
quantity one year
well no it's basically saying we take
takes current date it's granular lysing
it's it's a weird operation I mean it is
useful it's it's next look what it
really is is next anniversary mm-hmm
birthday / that's right birthday plus
sealing of now - birthdate that's right
but if we do today plus quantity one
year it keeps there well the question in
this case is when is Stevens when is the
next birthday for Steven so it's not
just today plus one year no but what I
mean is that if we have already oh I see
yeah so next anniversary or a more
generalized form of that is you know
next instance of
this date criteria I have yeah well next
date instance hmm yeah but I don't even
know what that I mean I mean that is
useful it's like when is the if this
program started yeah if this is an
annual event mm-hmm right so yeah I mean
the this sort of ties in with the
calculus of dates problem that we looked
at a bit and date select because you can
set up a set of criteria that won't ever
be true and you have to have some sort
of state instance would always be true
because next date instance would be it
would have a base mmm it would have an
increment and the default would be from
when right and the default for that
would be now so in the case of um I
think that's that's a sensible thing
because that would be right so what that
would look like is in the case of a
birthday it would say next date instance
of whatever it is birth date
you know this thing here right increment
one year and then from when it would
default to now oh but that's not saying
that granularity but it is that I see
it's the it takes picks up the guy
narrative the base yeah and so I guess
we can infer from the increment what the
the factor we're modding out is is you
give a specific instance of a date on
again
a year and we know since the increments
is years that we basically need to look
at switching out the the year spy right
it's a couple of points on the live
stream so another one is next leap
second and so next leap year which we do
not have right now it's great is that we
need a time system for what I mean there
are different there leap seconds
forget leap seconds leap seconds is the
whole UTM you know all that kind of
thing which we eventually gonna have
right um which we needed for the Eclipse
yeah let's make sense but I mean next
date instance what would we do here so
we would say we would I mean this would
be kind of an abuse to say leap year
here yeah I mean you know a lot of this
starts to get into calendars which is
complicated because then we want to
extend it to holidays and holidays
suddenly have more complicated criteria
of the second Tuesday of this month
which then we need some way of
specifying you know if I just give a
start date and we say it happens every
year is just gonna mod out the year
value but if I say I want the next
instance of Easter it needs to know that
we're working on a specific calendar
etcetera Santa just wrote a nice piece
of code for the next birthday
why didn't you submit it to the function
repository it will be useful there um
now I said does that deal with the
people born on the 29th of February when
do people born on the 29th of February
celebrate their birthday didn't know
anybody born on the 29th of February
March 1st yeah and what did they do they
go absolutely wild no no no no I'm
asking because she said she actually
knew somebody born on I have a friend
who was bought who is born on February
29th and we celebrate his birthday on
March 1st
but it
more species than there is actually a
favorite 29 it's complicated when you're
dealing with animals you know how do you
convert dog ears I know there are some
stories that have a return policy a
one-year return policy and if you buy
something on February 29th you actually
get a four year return policy oh but
they actually just like sure why not
that's funny
it's February 29 sale okay this is that
set that's an absolutely screwy case
right for any calendar system yeah
systems that have lead months things get
complicated too who has a leap month the
Islamic and Jewish calendars have leap
months Mayan also I think I they they're
a bunch of different Mayan calendars but
I think it's every six years there's a
13th month but I think things start 70s
every 19 or 18 in the Jewish kinda so
it's like every three or so all right we
need a discussion it sounds to me like
we need a date this discussion anyway do
we I mean Nick you are you steaming
ahead out we should wrap this meeting
but but you steaming ahead with your um
with your date stuff or not yeah we're
working on a couple of things Jose and I
are actually talking this morning about
needing to set up a meeting to talk
about data interval with you and a
couple other projects so we'll have that
colourings whatever happened to temporal
logic well so the so Johnny's kind of
busy now with his studies but we still
continue that now what what we
discovered in our last meeting is that
we need to extend it more we were kind
of looking into two small project from
your point of view so so yeah
alright alright although at some point
we also need to merge that with the
whole spatial logic stuff because that's
gonna be another and that that then
relates to the whole region business and
topology and all this kind of thing
right being able to say inside outside I
think yes there is the algebra for
relations with intervals and I think
this is what yeah all right well we
should wrap up for right now I think we
have actually another lifestream meeting
in just an hour
um okay good stuff thank you everybody
here thank you folks on the livestream
I'm talk to y'all soon bye